oh look at this you know let's let's
just use rice in the yeah why not
it's a celebration ratio you're with
Canadian yes we love to love Canadians
mm-hmm
Carlos Bustamante et Canada I haven't
slept Carlos what a time to be alive for
you you know uh I wrapped Westworld at
9:00 a.m.
huh Cheers espresso martini
cheers to to just be in here man get
over here hey yeah thank you man it's
good to be here so you know with a
fandom like Breaking Bad's the idea that
they're gonna do something new write a
movie let's make this movie there isn't
there always a risk that people will say
like I can't
Danny was perfect yeah I want to see I
didn't wanna see what goes up what was
your take on that I would normally think
that but we are dealing with Vince
Gilligan here hmm
and he is so cautious I mean you should
have seen him the final 16 episodes of
Breaking Bad I mean he was always kind
of stressed case just wanting to make
everything perfect I mean when I say
stress case I don't really I mean it
wasn't like Frankie he just was you know
so he just wanted it to be perfect that
was it and so when he approached me on
this before you wrote anything he just
sort of had an idea of what he thought
the arc could be but he wanted to see if
I was down and I of course was yes
offense whatever you want right but I
agree with you I mean I think they
really nailed the landing with Breaking
Bad the ending and that's very hard to
do when ending a series especially one
that's so loved you know you're messing
with a legacy here but Vince wouldn't
just do it to do it I mean he knows he's
messing with the legacy hmm and so he
told me is like look if it's not perfect
I don't want to do it but I don't want
to go down this journey and
I know you're on board and I'm like I
yes of course I'm on board
yeah and then about seven months later
gives me a call and said it's done and I
think it's perfect yeah so here we are
how hard was it or maybe it was easy for
you to get right back into that
headspace I mean it was easy man
Jesse's been through hell yeah yeah
Jesse's been through hell and and even
more so after you sort of read this
script and know this journey this next
chapter you get a deeper look at what
that hell truly was just a little bit of
that hell yeah and I mean you see how
these scars on his face came to be and
just the true torture that he went
through all being imprisoned in that
compound and so for me it was it was
incredibly easy to set kind of zip on
that skin again um but also I was
playing him slightly different because
he said a different man you know the
fans are gonna be dissecting this a lot
yeah gonna be talking quite a while
about certain things that happen I mean
those spoilers certain certain
characters that are in it certain
characters are not in it are you looking
forward to those discussions you think
you'll be part of that discourse as well
I think so yeah I'm you know I'm so
excited to just first of all talk about
the movie and I kind of keep it a secret
anymore it's nice to finally have it out
there and the fact that it's it's gonna
be on people's screens and young cinemas
across the country in just a few days
from now it's incredibly exciting and
I'm incredibly proud of of this film and
the work that everyone did on it on
screen and off and so it's a good
journey cheers to them and shirasaka me
you know there's where's my chocolate
espresso martini well how'd you get your
message out dos hombres let's go it's
outside okay yeah